Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
It's that and then the next paper view
is Holly Holm versus Germane Jermaine
Durand Domain,
which is,
it's a tough sell,
right?
It's a very good site.
I would buy it as a hardcore Farron,
I'll buy it for sure.
For sure.
And we'll probably,
but the bottom line,
a hundred a hundred thousand people.
Well
yeah,
yeah.
It ain't gon be Connor Mcgregor numbers.
Right.
Bottom line.
Connor when she lost it and
I'm sure he likes Rhonda by,
but business wise he's like excellent.
Excellent.
Yeah,
it's,
well,
it's a tricky situation now
with the marketing campaign,
the dumb yet WME WME
put together for this.
That was so Rhonda heavy and then Rhonda
gets smashed and now what are you going
to do for what you're going to
like the girl who smashed Rhonda,
is that what Amanda gets
for her next title fight?
You do a press tour.
World press or with her like let's,
let's introduce you to the girl.
Beat the shit out of Rhonda
now she's not fighting.
Let's do this press tour that
she deserves all this stuff.
Piggy back on Ronda again.
Yes.
And show the beating.
Well,
you know,
she sort of retired two
legends in the sport.
That's why she's my fighter of the year.
She retired and then she retired.
Rhonda if Rhonda retires,
that's huge.
She retired.
Both of them.
All of a sudden Amanda is Nate Diaz.
Did you see cat Zingano
posted on Instagram that
Amanda blocked her cause cats
and Gano uh,
stopped Amanda and Amanda was a hurting
cats and gone old bad in the first
round.
Real bad.
A cat was in big fucking trouble,
but she survived and went on to stop.
Amanda and I love cat but I'll,
I'll,
I'll uh,
fucking Amanda could do is like,
you lost the chick I just
beat and 17 seconds with will,
but she got caught in an arm bar.
I mean,
how did Amanda lose the fight?
I don't remember.
She beat her down.
She beat her down in the third round.
Cat got on top and started
blasting her and she kind of gas.
No.
Well she kinda gas but it was,
pat is ferocious.
Castlemont's Amanda,
you don't that fucking scream.
This is a recording of Cat
Zingano screaming after
she won that fight and it's
so primal,
dude.
It's like an animal screen.
I think you played it before
on the podcast because it was,
it was like punch.
You did it.
I was like,
Whoa,
there's some shit you here.
That's it.
God Dog.
Come on man.
That shit that's in your bone.
But that's after all that darkness.
She dealt with it.
Her husband committed suicide and
just all this diabetes was that.
That was after that is.
That was the virus afterwards.
It was the play that again,
Jamie,
play that again.
Listen to me.
Shit.
That shit makes you can for Roche's,
but to answer your question from before,
not to interrupt you.
This sitting on a fucking gold,
William Morris.
Now with this fuck of the man that Nunez.
I told you last night,
she's probably the LBGT community.
Jack [inaudible] fucking pockets.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Pocket Ltg.
It's Lbgtq a.
Now listen,
God damn.
What does that got to keep up lesbians,
gays,
while the old picture of music,
I don't know how to
change a lottery ticket.
They just hit the fucking lottery thing.
ASEXUALS are in there today
and Liz Carmouche before that,
but it looks,
she was still fit outs,
but Liz Carmouche wasn't
the champion work.
Once you're the chair,
she's the champion.
Press everything.
And when Liz Carmouche fought Ronda,
she fought her at the first fight
when no one knew who Ronda was.
So Rhonda has all this hype behind her.
She wins that fight and then goes on.
And you know,
Liz has done well in the UFC,
but having that it does,
it's not the same.
My manager,
she has her victor,
she's awesome.
Have you ever seen her fight?
Tony?
Ebinger very tough.
I don't think she is bad ass.
He's an eviction.
Super tough.
She's really good.
And she's opened the gay too.
And what way does she,
she's hilarious man.
I love that chick.
Uh,
she's like one 35,
one 35 one 45.
She's good man.
This is going to be more,
it's,
it's the same thing we were talking about
like when Anderson was in his prime,
when he was just a light
and people on fire,
the division was like,
there wasn't,
you know,
you had to like a,
Patrick Otay had a couple of
fights for the title Talus latest.
We're like,
there's no one,
there's no,
well rich Franklin was the champ,
but there's no overwhelming
need to see that fight.
You know what I mean?
Like you want to see the fight,
cause I'm interested in,
see Patrick's got a great chin,
he's got power.
Let's see what happens.
But it's not like,
oh,
here's the next one.
It's like Cody Garbrandt
fight and Dominick Cruz,
we were like,
oh,
let's see what happens here.
There was no one like that for
Anderson for a long ass time.
And I think in the women's
Bantam Weight Division,
you've got to kind of similar situation.
Now it's like,
now you have Amanda Nunez
who beats the shit out of me.
Hsa me is going a step back.
She's gone now.
She beats the shit out of,
uh,
Rhonda.
Rhonda steps back.
Holly goes up to one 45
change remainder random man,
you got to change that shit.
Why?
Why not have a man to fight for both belts
to save that card?
Fuck yeah.
I mean it make some moves cause,
cause if you've seen the car window,
the cop or man Holly's are prominent card.
How is the headliner?
That's what I'm saying.
Holly's fighting Germane to
random me for the one 45 pounds.
I thought they should give Jermaine Demand
Jamais thousand dollars that she does
already beat her by the way they need it.
None of beat.
Who I thought Nunez Nunez
already beat Jorin Jemaine Duran.
Yeah,
she beat her in the UFC.
Yeah.
Jermaine is a wicked kid.
Kickboxer her.
She's a world world class.
Multiple time world champion.
Kickboxer I think she's,
I think she won the Moitai world.
[inaudible] title several occasions.
She's like really elite
as a more time for fun.
But they'd gloves stand up,
always stand up.
There's no ground.
As soon as she got in the UFC,
you could see like that transition
between learning the striking with a,
with,
with take downs versus just
fighting to kickbox about.
It's a big transition.
Takes time.
Yeah.
But you're also going,
people aren't going to give you the time.
Exactly.
They're just fucking shooting
in our beating her up and
taking her down and it's
just,
it's just a different sport.
I thought the card was pretty good.
It's in Brooklyn.
Yes.
Travis Browne is fight.
Derrick Lewis.
That's an interesting fight.
But what's,
you know,
I mean,
what is true,
where's Travis Travis's
head out right now?
He's trained the same camp,
isn't he?
Yes.
God dammit.
Travis.
Yeah.
Holly Holm versus Amanda Nunez.
That's the fight right there.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I think at one 35 nights a
fucking should do that at this.
Uh,
for this card.
No.
Make it,
make a man of the two belt champion.
But then you have to remember
the Valentina Shevchenko
just beat Holly and has
come off 10 losses.
Yeah.
And Valentino beat her up.
Stand up.
Right Hook.
Fold
those two together.
Yeah.
They need help with this car.
The problem is most people,
even though Valentino one,
they don't know who she is yet,
even though she won,
I mean she needs a few more victories
inside the UFC in order to get people
excited.
Paper view this paper.
Yeah.
Brooklyn.
The only reason people know Holly too
is they don't know the her past losses
really?
They granted her flight was on Fox,
but all they knows she's the
girl that knocked out Rhonda.
That's what selling is.
Heady,
Bro.
You trying to say that this isn't
going to get you last 60 bucks.
I'm just saying that I
will illegally stream it.
Last one,
Amanda Nunez just fought for 45 seconds.
She's fresh.
Have her headline that car.
Hey Man,
let's build her up with,
where's the fire?
Where's the fire?
Is that the Superbowl card?
Yeah.
Damn.
I know.
I agree with that.
Yeah,
that's not,
that's February saying no,
no.
Super Bowl weekend is in Houston.
All different card.
Oh,
it is?
Yeah,
totally change in one.
I don't think they have
that card locked up either,
by the way.
I think there's still moving fights
around for that Brooklyn Card because I
think they recognize that that did
need a little bit more juice on that
card and Vegas this year.
No,
it's not finished.
It's in Houston this year.
And the soup bowls and Hughes.
She,
yeah.
Or is it new bronc Houston or Dallas?
I thought it was Dallas is a Houston,
Texas,
Texas.
So that's a,
they'll have a big card for,
uh,
for the UFC there.
They don't hate you,
man.
That's a great fight.
Now is a Bermudez and chance on John.
That's a good fight.
But what,
what a day is that?
Yes.
That would sell seven paper.
February 5th,
fourth Superbowl's on the fifth.
This is the fourth.
Yeah.
So one of those cards,
I'm not there for that.
You need to slow down,
sir.
Jesus Christ that sold us the fight.
That's a Superbowl cart
and it's a fight night.
Wow.
What's a soup bowl?
We Superbowl week.
That's [inaudible] the f the 29th.
The game is on the fifth.
Yeah.
That's the night before.
It's a free,
free fight night because
Superbowl weekend,
it's always been a,
uh,
paper v UFC.
Yeah.
It's usually been in Vegas.
Vegas.
Yeah.
I wonder whether Dillon,
man
[inaudible].